- We're back with Sterling K. Brown.
(audience cheering and clapping)
His show, "This Is Us"
is back on NBC starting January 4th.
So, let's talk "This Is Us".
Like, how are you feeling?
Is it bittersweet?
Because this is such a brilliant cast.
The chemistry has done so well.
It's such a popular show.
And it's just such a great message
to the family vibe from the show,
which has been so great overall.
So, is it kind of bittersweet for you?
Are you excited to do other things,
but you're also like kinda sad?
- That's exactly what it is.
I love the show.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It's been one of the best
six year ride of my life.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Like professionally,
it's been absolutely amazing.
Beautiful people.
I'm looking at my Black
Pearson family over here,
and I've gotten a chance
to see these three little girls
grow up over time.
Like every time I'm on
stage with them, alright,
I'm, I'm gonna miss them.
And I see their parents who
were backstage with them,
and I was like, "I love your daughters."
- And you've watched them grow up.
- And I've literally watched them grow up.
So once we start to get to like the last
two or three episodes,
there'll be something that happens
that I won't be able
to stop from happening.
- Oh, no.
- Because I know I'm
actually saying goodbye.
- Right now, I'm like "Oh, we're
having a great time" and
just blah, blah, blah.
When it gets to the end,
- [Kelly] Oh no.
- there'll be no acting.
- It'll be ugly cry.
- It'll be ugly.